Hey Natalia, wahrscheinlich ein Kristall, oder ich habe
zwei Fragen an dich. Die erste
, bevorzugst du es, Schauspielerin oder
Musikerin zu sein, die zweite, woher bekommst du
all deine Ideen für dein Wissenschaftsforum
? Ich hoffe, du beantwortest diese
Fragen und hast eine  Toller Tag, am
liebsten
möchte ich Schöpferin sein. Das einzige, was ich wirklich wirklich
für den Rest meines Lebens tun möchte, ist,
ein kreatives Leben zu führen. Ich glaube nicht, dass
ich Schauspielerin sein könnte, weil ich es will
Um die Geschichte zu schreiben, möchte ich keine Rolle
spielen, die ich selbst spielen möchte. Ich habe das Gefühl,
ich habe meine eigene Lebenserfahrung, meine
eigene Meinung, und es wäre eine Verschwendung,
immer eine Rolle zu spielen, von der ich mich losgelöst fühle,
deshalb  Ich liebe es, Songs
für mich selbst und andere Leute für Filme und
Soundtracks zu schreiben. Ich liebe es, Regie bei meiner eigenen
Webserie mit Kurzfilmen zu
führen  kreative
Lebensmusik und Regie und Schreiben
b  Bücher und Drehbücher, woran ich
gerade arbeite, stehen immer an
erster Stelle
du